パマーラは悪いというブッダの立場
これもわかったような顔してはいけないんですよ
なぜならば我々はもうパマーラでかっこいいのに
我々から見ればね 自分やりたいことをやって生きること自体成功でしょうに
山を登りたいと思ったら山を登れたらそれで成功でしょうに
店を開いたいと思ったところで
店 店を開くことができて
商売はちゃんと調子に乗ってるんだったら
まあ成功者でしょうね
何が不幸ですかね それが
自分にぴったし合う相手を見つけて結婚できたならば
これが幸せでしょうに
何が苦しいんですかね
だから それがまたパマーラの生き方でしょ
だからパマーラが悪いとお釈迦様
まあそれはその通りですと
あまり調子に乗ってはいけない
わかるはずがないんですよ
だから次のステージ パマーラは苦しみの元になるんだという
パマーラがある限り人間は安らぎがないんだというところは
また新たに研究勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
楽じゃないんですよ この言葉に引っかかっちゃうと
まあ一応これで あの アッパマーラの説明は要らないからね
一応 本当にパマーラで我々は不幸ですかね
で ここでパマーラ的な生き方
またもう一度見なくちゃいけないんですね
私たちはこの衝動のままで
本能のままで生きていることでしょう
いわゆるやりたい放題の生き方でしょ
思うがままの生き方でしょ
これすっごく落とし穴があるんですよ
成長ということ 向上ということはまるっきりない
あの ものすごい硬い殻の中に
熱い鉄板でできてる箱の中に生きているような感じ
どこまででも成長するってことは成り立たないんですよ
考えてみると いわゆる本能が要求するがままに生きるんだから
本能って何なのかとも知らんでしょうし
要求すればそれを与えてあげようとする
それで我々持っている本能やら何やらなんか分からないんだけど
そういうものはどんどん向上して発展していっぱいになるっていうことはないんです
まあかえって置き換える論理だからね
置き換える論理だけど
本能がやっぱりいろんなものを期待するんですよ
そこで期待するものを与えちゃえばいいと思っちゃうんです
もう一つ忘れてる なんであれこれと要求するんですかと
自分の心が あれこれで要求するものをその今のままでやってあげることは幸せだと思ってるでしょ
でもなんでそんなに注文がうるさいんですかと
自分の心は それでは具体的に考えてみてください
えらい注文がうるさい人って何ですかね
あれ欲しい これ欲しい
えー違う違う それじゃないとかね
結局はその心 えらい苦しんでるんです
不満なんです 不満があればあるほど要求はうるさいんですよ
要求の数々が増えるだけじゃなくて
その要求に対してまたさらに条件までつけるんですよ
カバンが欲しいんだけど
それで終わらない この色で
この重さで このデザインで
この形で このブランドで
このメーカーで また店まで
あの店で買わなきゃとかね
これはすっごい苦しんでるんですよ
もうわかりやすい例で
このフランス人もイタリア人もそれほどブランド品には凝ってないんですよ
そこそこ手作りで何か着てかっきょうているんだけど
こちらに来てみたら フランス製でイタリア製でないと死にますよ
借金でもしてどうしても必要だからと
感じないイタリア人っていうのは何でも着るんですけど
これまたブランド着てる人よりはかっこいいんですね
悪いことに また上品で
これは心の苦しみの度合いですよ
苦しみが増えれば増えるほど
要求にはあらゆる条件ついてきます
これでこのままではダメ
金持ちにならなくては
こちらの東京のアパートはダメダメ
もっと環境のいい空気のいいところに行かなくちゃとかね
あるんだけど やっぱり交通は便
交通便がちゃんとできてなきゃとかね
もうあれこれとか条件つけてつけてつけて
生活する人と まあまあいいんじゃないかというふうに思ってる人の
どちらの心が悩みが多いんですかね
だから 意のままに生きていて成功したいというならば
成功を収めたというならば
その人の心が激しく揺らいで悩んでいるということなんです
もうわがままでもなかなかもう満足させるということは無理不可能な状態
そこで満足することは無理不可能な状態が強烈になればなるほど
まあ頑張る 放逸になる
なって 俗世間で言うあのくだらない成功を収めたという
それで仏教はもうちょっと考えて
あんた成功を収めたと威張ってるんだけど
見てみるとあんたの状況は
と ずーっと苦しんでるはずなんです
穏やかじゃないんです
笑えないんです だから心の要求が少ない人っていうのはよく笑うんですよ
世の中で一番美しい可愛い笑顔っていうのは赤ちゃんですよ
何も知らん 何が必要かも知らんですよ
赤ちゃんは まあ泣いたりはしますけど
まあ自分でも何で泣くかとわからない
まあお腹が おそらくお腹が空いてるでしょうと
お母さんが考えなきゃ
それぐらい要求があることさえも気づいてないんだから
ちょっと笑っちゃうとすっごい可愛いんですよ
大人が喜ぶために大人同士ですごくどれほどお金かかる知ってますか？赤ちゃんがちょっとニコッと笑っただけで
まあ楽しくてみんな そういうことだから
やっぱり要求が赤ちゃんもどんどん大きくなって
えらい憎たらしい [笑い]状態になるでしょうに
要求増えるんですよ 親にももう手に負えないです
状態になるんだから 赤ちゃんだけできるならば
10人でも全然問題はないんですよ
でも要求が増えていくんですよ
赤ちゃんだったら 10人ぐらいの面倒っていうのは何などうったことはない
まだ笑ったりするんだからね
これまた楽しい これ 10人が 10歳ぐらいになったことを考えちゃうと
まあ逃げた方がいいですね
怖くなるんですよ 要求が増えるんです
そういうことで この意のままに生きるということ
思うがままに生きるということは
心がかなり不満で 満足感がなくて
あれこれこれこれと要求するだけ
それで心って何なのかわかってもないし
心はちゃんともののこと知ってるかっていうことも知らないし
心が要求するものは本当に心に対していいものか悪いものかも知らんでしょ
だからまだ危険なんですよ
これよく人生の中であるでしょうね
あれはどうしても欲しいと我々いろんないろんなものを獲得したりするでしょうね
獲得して あれ これでもなかったと
いつでもあるでしょう
そういうことは あの人ならあの人はもう結婚相手がすごくいいやと思って決めて判断して結婚したんですけど
あれちょっと違うと ということは
心が正しく判断していないんですよ
時々子供はね とにかく医者になってやろうと思って頑張って医者になったら
こんな仕事嫌やと ろくなことはないと
思ったりするし 弁護士になりたい人々も
やっぱり自分が何を仕事しようとしているんだと
悪いこと私にも聞いたことありますからね
あなたの話を聞くとなんか私は犯罪を犯して生きているような感じになっちゃったんだよと
だから仕事を通しても
いわゆる犯罪者やらね
そういう人々を助けることだから
なんか自分本当にいいことやってるんですかと
教えてくださいという風にことになる
だから自分の心が要求したんだから弁護士になったでしょうに
なってみたらやっぱり違うと
また今更何をと それで食べ物を見たら
これが食べたい 美味しいなと決めるでしょうに
食ったこともないのに
よく決めること それで食べてみたらやっぱり別なものいいやと
またになる だからこの
意のままに生きるということは幸せかと
自分の意識が要求 意識が智慧があって
きちんとして判断できて要求するんだったら問題ないんですよ
ということは プロの医者は患者さん
患者さんを見て あんたはこの薬使いなさいと言うと
いくら高くてもその薬をあげたっても悪くないんですよ
自分の国の場合は土地や家を家を売ってでも
その場合は薬あげたりしますよ
日本ではそういうことはないんですけど
でもそれは悔しくないんですよ
この子供は大事にするやら
まあ時々この薬代とかは言うんだけども
人の 2日間ぐらいの収入というかね
一つの調剤 これがもう 1日3回やら2週間に 1本ずつとか言っちゃうと
びっくりするでしょ やっぱりそれでも家を
土地を売って ありとあらゆるものを売ってとかね
また人から何とかちょうだい
何とかちょうだいとかね
まあそうやってお金集めて
でもその自分の子供には手術するんですよ
それが別に悔しいことじゃないんですよ
それで一文無し状態になっても
子供が治ったらああ良かったとと思うでしょ
それがなぜかというと
このちゃんと専門家のプロの医師がこれが適した答えだと言うんだから
そこまででも頑張れるんですよ
では 自分の心はそういうものですかね
何でも知り尽くしてるんですかね
では 私は知ってますかね
私に対して一番適した
ふさわしい正しいものって何なのかと
誰も知らんでしょ 人に聞いてみていいですよ
あなたはどれぐらい才能を持ってるんでしょうかと
あなたにとって一番適職は何なのかと
知ってますかね 自分の心なのに
自分にとって何をできれば最高の幸せだと思っているんでしょうかと
何一つも知らないはずなんです
みんなまあやってみるしかないんだと
という曖昧な生き方で生きてるんですよ
まあしょうがない こういうことになったんだからとかね
女性の方々から見ると
まあしょうがない こういう風な家庭になったんだからとか言って
まあ中途半端で生きてるだけなんです
ということは 心が中途半端で何もわかってないんです
それで何もわかってない
いい加減な中途半端な判断能力ない心の要求を聞いてあげる生き方が幸せの元になるのかと
どう見たってもなれないはずなんです
そこで例で考えます しっかりした知識
知識人のお母さんがいる
ちっちゃな子供がいる
可愛い子供が随分遊びたくて楽しくて
そこで正しいのは 子供が言うことにお母さん従うことか
お母さんが言うことに子供が従うかということなんです
正しいのはどちらですかね
どちらと思いますか  どちらとも言えないと思います
で 二つ選んでください
二つの中で  通常ですと親の言うことを聞いて
子供が親の言うことを聞くのが一般的だと思います
それでも曖昧だから 答えはね
こんなの通常じゃなくて
これが正しい答えなんですよ
で 子供が言う親言う子供が親が言うこと
子供は聞かなくちゃいけないんですよ
そんなのは当たり前でしょうに
子供って何もわかってないでしょうに
親がご飯作ってくれるから食べるわ
それでまだまだ三歳にもなってないんだから
一日中遊んでるだけで
これで完璧わけじゃないでしょうに
ということだから 知識人の母親が言うことは否応なしに子供はやらなくてはいけないんですよ
これが常識というもので
倫理というものなんです
大人になりたければ 幸せになりたければ
しっかりと一人前でいきたければ
まぁ 親の言うことを聞くことです
それはもう選択はない
だからどちらでも言えないということは全くダメですよ
子供の言うことは決して親が聞いたらいないんです
親が言うことは子供は聞くべきなんです
親が子供に自分で物事を判断できる能力を育て上げてやらなくてはいけないんです
だからずっと親がガイドラインを据えてガイドリード指導っていうものをしなくちゃいけない
子供が言うことを一つ聞いちゃうと
それから終わりですよ
人生は あいつらすごい恐ろしいんだ
ものすごい怖い生き物ですよ
次から次へ次から次へと要求する
それで約束っていうのは一つも守らない
いくら約束をさせようと思っても
見事に脱線するんですよ
これは政治家よりもすごい能力はね
これぐらい厳しい私にもできるんだから
約束させるっていうことは
いろんな方向で話を持っていっても
では約束だよというところになってくるとツルッとするんです
だからそこまでそういう戦術を読んでいるんですよ
これが約束しても自分のバカな聞いてくれないんだ
大人の思うほどじゃないんです
恐ろしい それで そういうことだから
一つでも子供の考え方に気持ちにめげちゃうと
一生苦労する羽目になるんです
だから それは子供いじめなさいという意味じゃないんですよ
子供は遊ぶのは当たり前で
遊びながら勉強するのはそんなの子供のやり方で
子供に対して立ち向かうやり方でしょうし
だからといって遊んでもいいよとかね
そういうふうに言ってはいけないんです
例えば八時に勉強始まりますからね
遊ぶならばそこまでですよとかね
と言ってもいいんですよ
いいよ よく遊んでこいとか
それは言ってはいけない
微妙に言葉遣いっていうのはね
そこはどうでもいい話で
まぁ一応一般的に言えば
まあお母さんが言うことを聞いた方が正しいんですよ
それで自分の人生になってくると
私たちはそれは逆さまにしているんです
子供が言うことに親が奴隷のように従うと
子供の命令は親が聞くと
言うと話にならんでしょうに
子供は家の主人で お母さんこうしなさい
ああしなさいと 言うと
お母さんにもう幼稚園に行きましょうということ言えないでしょうに
これはでは話にならないんです
これではもう生きていられないんです
何にも成り立たなくなっちゃうんですよ
だからすべての 例えば精神的な異常者を議員候補者を選ぶとかね
知識障害者を選挙に出すとか
なぜ勝ってあげるかと
勝たせてあげるとどうなるんですかね
だからなんでここまで言いますかというと
私という個人が心が言うことを聞いているでしょ
堂々と 全然それが間違っていると思ったこともないでしょ
では 家の主人が赤ちゃんにしてみればどうなるんですかね
赤ちゃんではなくて それなりの子供にしておけば
何食べるかと 晩御飯に何するが
朝ご飯に何をするかと
全部子供が決めると 何時に起こるかと起きるかと
子供が決めると 成り立ちますかね？子供は朝起きてご飯も食べて
今日はお父さんと遊びますからと決めたら
お父さんが仕事に行かないで子供に相手しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
きっとそういう成り立たないでしょ
それを言う危険なことを私たちはずっとやってるんです
何も理解していない心
何もわからない心が言うことをやってあげる
それで幸せだとも言う
その上でも 生き方は幸せだとも言うんです
これはもう馬鹿無知だと言っていいられるところじゃないんですよ
このpamada的な生き方が不幸の元やというのはそういうわけなんです
アホな無知な何もわかってないところの意のままでしょうと
幸せになるはずがないんだ
だからあんた方幸せだということは本当は錯覚だと
会社に行こうとしたお父さんを子供が今日はお父さんと遊ぶ予定計画ですよと言った時も
はい わかりました ご主人様付き合わせてくださいと
すぐ会社に行かないで子供と遊ぶと
そこで子供は行きたいというところに連れて行って
やりたいという遊びをやってやらせてあげて
子供は本当に今日は楽しかったねお父さんと
そうですね 楽しかったと
あれ楽しかったんですかね
その連中は不幸の原因作ってるでしょうに
それで次にお父さんがクビになるでしょうに
だからその幸せは錯覚なんです
錯覚ですけど 楽しかったというのはもう確かに楽しかったかもしれませんよ
仕事に行かないで子供と 1日遊んだということはね
そこら辺はすごい質が悪いというかね
判断しにくいところなんですけど
だから我々の楽しみっていうのは
そんなものは会社を辞めて
じゃあ子供の子供と砂遊びするために相手してあげたと
学校に今日は楽しんだから学校に行きそうと言った子供は
突然お父さんに電話かけて会社に学校にいたくなる
もう学校帰りたくなっちゃったんだけど
お父さん早く帰ってこいと
これから遊びたいんだからと言ったら
お父さんがすぐ会社を仕事を辞めて
学校に行って子供を連れ出して遊ぶというふうな生き方をやってます
我々は それは楽しくないと言っても楽しいでしょ
子供楽しいんだから 自分の意のままだから
でもそういう生き方は
正しくはないんです それでは不幸なんです
今我々こんなバカどもたちの地球で
でもいくらかうまくいくんですけど
このバカの同士の中でもいくらか知識ある人々は管理しているんだからなんです
でないとうまくいかんでしょうに
知識ない能力ない人々は訓練を受ける
例えば電車の操縦というのは誰でもやってもいいわけじゃないでしょうに
これはずっと訓練を受けて受けて受けて受けた人には
もう我々よりは素晴らしく能力ある
ですから 一センチ 二センチの誤差でちゃんと電車を止まってくれる
あれ単純だからね あの
なんとかあれを前に出すか下引っ張るか
それだけでしょう だから子供にもできるんだからやらせてみてみたらどうですかね
子供ゲームでやってますから
あれの操縦ぐらいは知ってますよ
でも子供にやらせちゃうとどうなるかわからないでしょうに
危険でしょうに だからむちゃくちゃ訓練受けて
何年も見習いしてからやっと自分で電車一本回して
回してくれるんです それで我々は無事
無事故であちこち旅をする
そのように世界はいつでも私より能力ある人が管理しているんだからうまくいってるんですよ
電気のトラブルが来たら電気屋さんに頼む
その人々は私よりは能力を持っている
屋根が雨漏りすると そこら辺のその関係の人を頼む
という生き方をしているんだから
なんとか無事生きてるでしょ
でなきゃ 愚か者しか存在しないこの地球はどうなるんですかね
それでたまたま精神異常者がね
ヒットラーやらブッシュ大統領やら
そういう異常者が出たらどうなるかと
ということで 危険です
で 私たちはこの幸せや楽しみだっていうことも錯覚で
本当は私より能力ある人々に支配されているんだからなんですよ
よく見ると 学校もある
会社もあるとかね 政府もあるとかね
どこを見ても私という個人から見れば
みんなそれぞれその世界で私よりは能力を持っている
それで安全で無事で生きているというぐらいのことです
だからその社会を見てもその事実見えるはず
教えるのがすごい上手な先生たちがいる学校だったらうまくいくんですよ
教える能力ないだけじゃなくて
人格もできてない先生たちが集めちゃうと
もうこれはもう校内暴力で終わっちゃうんですね
人を殺したりして あるいは殺されたりとか
だから未熟なものに管理を与えるものじゃないんです
なのに自分一人の人生になってくると心の声を聞く
それが智慧のある人から見れば
それほど危険なことはないんです
プロに任せるべきですよ
それでお釈迦様は言われるんです
放逸は不幸の元やと そういう放逸アッパマーダはすべての苦しみの元やと
俗世間で考えたっても
なんで戦争あるんですかね
なんで互いに人殺しやってるんですかね
いつでも支配者がバカになった時なんです
支配者が抜群の知識人だったら
その国は悪くならないでしょうに
愚かな感情で 見栄で 盲信で
妄想に支配されて政治経済やると
こんな状態になるでしょうに
だから世界を見ても 無知な心に支配されてらひどい目に遭う
そういうことだから 世界-- 世界をいくら見てもいつでも矛盾であって
どうかわからないという状態になるんです
例えば科学を-- 科学が発展すればするほど
人間は極度に幸福になるはずなんですけど
ならないんですね 面白いことに
いろんな技術 機械 何のために発明するかというと
人間に楽をさせるためでしょ
すごい速さで走る もうね
飛行機やら新幹線のぞみやら開発しちゃうと
人間には何か時間の余裕があって
楽々で 本当にそうなっているの？時間の余裕あるの？遊ぶ時間あるんですかね
結果は逆でしょうに 何なのかね
これは 医学は開発すればするほど人間はもう病に倒れないはずでしょうに
でも結果は病気になることっていうのは昔も今も全然変わりはない
面白いことに結核にかかったらもう薬は効かないでしょ
今は 怖いじゃないですか
肺炎でも薬効かないという
だからこれ何でしょうかね
例えば経済はものすごく昔と信じられないほど違うでしょ
昔みたいに大根 10本ぐらいやっと作って
どこかに行って売って
ちょっと米ちょっともらうとか
そんな経済じゃないです
今は 米ちょっと作った人が米一合ぐらい持って隣に行って
これでちょっと野菜と交換いかがでしょうかと 「
はい わかりました」と米もらって
その人から野菜もらうとか
それでもう野菜とご飯食べるでしょう
向こうも野菜あるんだけど
米がないんだから こっちは米一合もらったんだからね
それでお粥でも作って食べるってことでしょ
そういう経済ですか 今あるのは
信じられないぐらい経済
たった 1分で 1千  5千万っていうのは軽々と儲かる世界でしょ
株の場合は 買って 1分以内で売ると
こちら 5千万円と そんなに軽々と経済活動できるのに
本当に幸せ？本当にみんな豊か？今時で誰も飢え死になってない？どころか
私のような状況にいる人だったらね
もうビンラディンみたいに怒るぐらいの状況なんですよ
俺も こちらでくだらない何か薬を開発しましたと
でもその病気に効くかというと
今はこれしかないんだぞとか
そこで情報を流すんですよ
マスメディア 国々にまで
そこで注射一本は まあ 一万円とかね
円で言えば それで貧しい国々の医者さんには強引にそういう情報を流しちゃって
まあやっぱりこのお薬だよと
そこで特別に注文して輸入しないと
そこで一万円の薬はそちらに行くと三万円ぐらいになる
その人々はもう二ヶ月間やっと仕事しちゃうと一万円の収入なんですよ
それで死にかけている子供にこの薬あげなきゃと
これって幸せな状況ですかね
では 昔の自分の国でも子供たちがそんな死んだんですかね
死んでなかったんですけど
もう庭であちこちいつでも薬ありましたし
自然のものは そんなものを飲ませちゃって
で 昔の医者っていうのはお金もらわないんですよ
何か強引にお礼するしかないんです
一応何か持ってってお礼したっても
別にそれ見ようともしない
何ですか問題はとかね
だから貧しい人でもお金がある人がいたっても
医者の態度同じなんです
そこできちんと病気を治しちゃったし
癌なんかはもう聞いたことはないし
癌にならんでしょう 自然と一緒に生活すると
それでその医者たち追い出して
こんな薬草なんか使うもんじゃない
かっこいい錠剤なもんではないかとかね
あんた方は薬の薬草の油体をつけたりとかね
まあ薬をつけてる もうお風呂みたいなものに入ったりしてね
それで二日かかりますよと
これ飲んだらすぐもう三十分で頭痛は治りますよと
治るんですかね？この治らない頭痛だったら
この伝統的なアーユルヴェーダ治療だったら
やっぱり一ヶ月間かかります
治療には でも完璧に治るんですよ
細胞一個一個治してみるんです
頭痛ではなくて 病院に行ったらすぐ注射一本で帰ってく
あれ治ってるんですかね？それどれぐらいお金かかるか
だから結局この医学なんか発展して
結局人殺してるんです
でもそういう人々は決して人殺してやろうと思って研究してるわけじゃないんですよ
この病気になんとか自分たちが薬を開発して
ノーベル賞をもらって大金持ちになってやろうではないかという気持ちでやってますよ
特許まで取って 他人にはそれは使えないようにしてやるぞというすごい優しい気持ちで
遺伝子を解読したら絶対それをあげてはいけませんと
なんで？人がそれで役目立つんだと
あげるんだったら多く取り上げて金取りましょうと
という優しい人々ですけど
とにかくこの人を殺すという気持ちはないんですよ
しかし 結果としては人は死ぬんです
毎日毎秒 死んでるんですよ
だから世間見ても なんだかおかしいということなんですよ
誰に文句言ったって意味がないんだよ
シュワジェネガーみたいな人は選挙で勝つんだから
まあ人間っていうのは素晴らしい頭いいんですよ
もうとにかく 特別番組まで日本で作るんだからね
世界中を驚くべきほどの知識人がね
まあカリフォルニアの知事になってありがたいしね
で まあそんな世界でしょうしね
何なのかと 何かおかしいというね
これはどういうことですかね
これが一人一人の個人のいのままだからなんですよ
だから結果がもうあべこべで
むちゃくちゃで どうにもならん
金はあるんだけど幸せはないとかね
幸せなんですけど 金がないとか
お金はあるんだけど もう性格が悪く悪くて犯罪者とかね
という世界でしょ これ何一つも理にかなってない世界に納得している人々っていうのは
どれほど心が無知かと
何を見ても理にかなってないんですよ
例えばすごく勉強が上手で頭が良くてもう淡々と判断できてる人にはいい仕事はないんですよ
それで軽々と金儲かるのはバカでアホで傲慢で強情で
もう無茶苦茶金儲かったりする
例えばある知識系の仕事にでも二人が願書を出したら
誰が選べるかというと
タチが悪い人は選べるんですよ
正直で控えめで淡々の仕事をしようと思ったら選べないんです
その時でも服装で決めるんですよ
だからそういう選ぶ人々も選ぶ人々もね
騙すのは簡単ですよ もうどこかですごい高級なブランドの服装レンタルで買って着ていけばいいんですよ
その日だけにプロのデザイナーを頼んでね
面接に行く時はね その人に 5 6万払ったって全然大丈夫です
ぴったし決めて バンダナのネクタイやらなんでも
女性だったらそれなりの服やらカバンやら全部レンタルでいいんです
そこで歩き方座り方ちょっと習って終わったら
それで二重丸で合格しますよ
それからやりたい放題
ダサいやり方でいいんです
そういう世界ではないんです
我々生きているのは だからたまに私物事うまくいかないと
それ知ってますから 世界のことは
ちょっとほんのわずか使いますよ
その知恵を 使った途端
見事にこちらの意通りになってくることあるけど
悲しくなるんですよ ここまで馬鹿ですかと
こういう人々っていうのは
例えば絶対できないことでもね
これがね せっかく私はあなたのところに来たら
これあなたにしかできないんだからよと
他の人を頼んだって意味がないんだから
よくやってくれますよ
本当は無駄な仕事なんですけど
ちょっと脅せばね あなたしか行く頼むところないんだから
で それだけで「あ そう
俺が偉いんだから どうしても」と
何とかしますということでちゃんとやってくれます
そういうことだから 世界見たら何か理不尽なところ
何かではなくて どこを見ても何かアベコベで
何か納得いかない 例えば日本は豊かな経済大国ですか？と聞いたらもう答えがないと思いますよ
まああの白い紙に書いてある数字見る見ればね
まあ大国ですけど 実際ないところに行ってみればね
なんとなくやり取りしているだけでしょうし
それで国政なんか見てみると
もう世界一赤字政治やってるでしょうし
大国どちらですかね 世界一赤字経済
さんでしょ その上 昼飯も買い与えてやるぞと思っているんだから
日本円で何倍大きいですかね
あの国は 収入はどれほどあるんですかね
あれで贅沢三昧で生きてる人々から何体いったことやったって満足しないよ
みんなに家作ってあげたとしても豪邸作ってあげないと
一人一人に イスラム人だから
こちら牛小屋で生活していて
牛小屋じゃなくてウサギ小屋っていうんですね
[笑い]ウサギ小屋に生活していて
こちらももう赤字で もうね
頭いいんですよ そこでイラクを復興してあげるとか
とにかくなんかおかしいでしょ
とにかく別にあれが あれが悪いこれが悪いということは言えませんだけど
なんかおかしいだけはおかしいでしょ
経済大国といえば それはそうなんですけど
と では豊かでしょうかといえば
またちょっと疑問で 経済がうまく行かないんだったら
収入がないっていうと
明らかにそんな人が壊す
壊す方で壊したところでこちらから作ってやるぞっていうことはね
できるでしょうかと それで壊し屋っていうのは簡単でしょ
分の仕事だから それで壊し屋にはどうぞ自由に頑張ってくださいと応援するのは何なのかと
なんでお前らが壊すと
壊したってのも作るのはこちらでしょう
いい加減しないかと なんで怒らないんでしょうかと
今度言うことを聞かなかったら絶対作りに行かないんだよと
でも壊し屋は自由自在で壊したい放題壊すと
それから復興する人々は命令聞いて
命令通りに従って復興しなくちゃいけない
どちらが楽ですかね どこを見てもね
世の中なんでこういう世界かというと
これ一人一人の心に問題なんです
これ 子供が管理しているんですよ
大人を だからどんな人間の判断も決断も
なんのアテにならない
だから私の心は言うことはアテにならないんですよ
私たちは幸せだ 幸せだと言うだけで錯覚です
ちょっと見てみなさい
だからお釈迦さんは結束が謎です
パマーダは良くないと
放逸は良くないと だから
意のままにやりたい放題やるんじゃないんです
では何をやればいいんですか？上だったら
これわからないでしょ
やりたい放題やるんじゃないというところで
では何を言われればいいかとわかる
だからパマー アッパマーダはわからないはずなんです
それで引き算でやるんです
だから引き算しか成り立たないんです
これ 引き算は簡単じゃないんですよ
心を諭さないと引きにならないんです
例えばタバコ吸いたいと
吸うなよと言ったらもう吸わないんですけど
腹が立つんですよ 心は
なんだこの野郎と タバコ吸いたいのにと
で また吸いたくなるんです
それで吸わないでしょ
さらに腹が立つんです
吸いたいなと だからそれはうまくいかないんです
ただいたずらやめても
物事 それで心を諭すんですよ
子供に何かやめてもらうために子供を諭さなきゃあかんでしょ
よく理解したら子供はすぐはい
わかったと やめてくれるでしょ
すごく可愛いです その時は
だからそう思うほど簡単じゃないんです
引き算は 足し算はもうバカでやる限りは簡単にできるんです
何か増えるだけだから
例えば修行の世界で断食するんだとかね
なんとか何とか毎朝三時に起きて
なんとか経典読るとかね
六時までとかね そういう足し算だったら
まあバカでやる限りはできますよ
私にはできません 今日は気分 거야
今日はやりたくないと思ったらやりませんから
バカはおびえて必ずしもやらなくちゃっていうことでやってくれます
だから足し算というのはどんな愚か者にもできますが
引き算はできませんよ
引き算のやり方 このタバコ一本吸うか吸わないかと
[終始背景音楽]それで心がそこは理解する
あ 分かった これが悪いんだ
ああ いや やれ やめましょうと
そうすると喜んでやめるんですよ
引き算になるんです ということで引いて引いていくと
心はどんどん智慧が開発していくんです
智慧のある人は不幸になりません
当たり前 今の世の中を見ても
我々は専門家に管理されているんだから
なんとか死なないで済んでいるでしょうに
だから自分の人生もそうやって幸福に管理されると
いわゆる智慧に智慧の心で管理されると幸福になります
ということで これが難しいんだから修行だと言っているんです
引き算は だから智慧も必要なんです
そこでそれがパマーダとアッパマーダの定義なんですと
説明 あまりにも単純ですけどね
それでもう一度二十六番目の偈を読んでみると
当たり前のこともわかるでしょう
もうやりたい放題なことで
若者はもうやりたい放題のことをやって喜んで生活しているんだと
しかし 智慧のある人はアッパマーダということに頑張るんだと
これが宝物やと思って
これが宝物なんですよ
九角形のアッパマーダは
パマーダでただふざけて喜んでいるだけ
宝物ではないんです で
なんでパマーダは宝物かというのは
そういうすごい深い意味があるんです
アッパマーダは宝物であるというのは
純粋な幸福への道なんです
ですから パマーダにはふけない方がよろしいと
二十七番目ね マーパマーダンアニオンジェーダ
パマーダはしてはいけない
やりたい放題のことをやって生きているんじゃないんだと
それでマーカーマラーティサントワン
それは説明しなかったんですけど
心というのは単純ですよ
食いたい 遊びたい 楽しみたい
お祭りに行きたい テレビを見たいとかね
これそれだけでしょ 友達と喋りたいとかね
大したことないです 聞きたい
見たい 食いたい 味わいたいとかね
これぐらいの五つのことで生きてますから
どうったことね これやりたい放題と思ってる
ただそれだけなんですよ
もう元々無知だからね
私はやりたい放題のことやって生きているんだぞと言ったって
ろくなことやってないんですよ
いろんなものを見ているか
いろんな音を聞いているか
いろいろ味を味わっているか
そんなもんです それで体にいろいろ感触を与えているか
車十台持ってるんだぞとかね
どうったことないんで
座れる乗れるのは一回一台しか
いくら頑張っても そこで歩く車に乗って
明日この車に乗るんだぞと
何ですかね ただ体の観測でしょ
まあそんなもんね いわゆる
何と言いますか やりたい放題
意のままに 思うがままに生きているんだよと言うんだけど
よくよく見るとなんだその程度かということなんです
食い物を探すだけのことでしょう
着るものを探すだけ 何か見るもの
綺麗なものを見たいと思って
例えばもう一万二万円
二万っていうところじゃなくて
十万 二十万 百万とか使ってちょっと花を飾っちゃうとかね
一か所の花飾りにもまあ二十万ぐらいかかったとかね
まあ二日三日で枯れますけどね
見るものでしょ 結局は
で 私はやりたい放題やってるんだと言うだけなんですよ
あれはもう考えてみると大したことではない
それでマーカーマラティサントーマというのはその意味なんです
あんた方はやりたい放題やってるんだと思ったけど
ただカーマ 欲に溺れてるだけですよと
欲っていうのは見るもの
聞くもの 嗅ぐもの 味わうもの
体に触れるものと五つです
だからこれは何かいきなりカーマ
欲が入ったことはちょっとおかしいんではないか